well you know this is an entertainment
tonight interview so i have to ask about
your personal life
the fans think you and gigi are more
than just sisters
of course me and gigi are
ready soulmates my first show cause
finally
now i don't hate the mirror i know
i know what the rumors are we've talked
about it we've been
socially long distant and um listen that
mullet does something
[Music]
it's so strange to like go on the show
and
you know i'm i'm friends with all the
girls but for some reason
her and i just can just were able to
connect really well
we're fans of like what each other do
and we like
both teach each other stuff it's so
weird
um i've been loving all of the um
fan videos of us like all our little
side parts where we're just laughing
and dancing together um and they always
put it to romantic music
we'll see we're in quarantine so we
haven't been able to spend that much
time together
but once we get back um
in the same room maybe we'll see how a
relationship goes and she said
she's uh excited to see where things go
when this whole quarantined lives and
you guys can see
i am true diva i wish we were
quarantined together but we are not we
talk as much as we can
and um i mean crystal is one of the most
special people i've ever met
she's incredible who do you want to be
america's next drag superstar
what does it mean to you to get to be in
top three with crystal
it's incredible it's i mean like like i
said before like
i'm gonna take the crown but if i didn't
in some crazy universe that i didn't
take the crown
i would be so honored and
happy to have it go to somebody like
crystal and even jada like
these girls are some of the best friends
that i have ever had and i
think the fact that our drag is all so
like so
different we are such different drag
queens and it's a top three like you've
never seen before so
if any one of us took it it would be
just incredible for the history of the
show
oh 100 i was saying to both jada and
crystal that u3 brings
each bring something so different to
this top three that it's gonna be
so exciting to watch the finale and then
watch where you guys go after this
yes absolutely i would love to tour with
them i would love to do shows with them
it's just like
i'm honored to be a part of this with
them i feel honored to like
be in the top three with jada and gigi
because
oh those are my talented sisters i love
them
well i am interested to see how this
finale goes and i
hope to see you and gigi you know having
cute couple moments on instagram yeah
creepy creepy forever